connaissant notre passé je sais que ça
fonctionne en traîneau mais andy suis là
ok et cette fois ce sera différent
j'ai loué cette voiture en arrivant à
l'aéroport la compagnie a fait une
erreur à l'eau
qu'il est toujours debout
il ya quelques jours j'ai obtenu des
informations compromettantes appliquant
un homme très haut placées vous conférez
tout seul la police c'est la police qui
veut ma peau
et vont nous tuer tous les deuils
direct aux cantons
ou encore
vous avez enfin votre libération
conditionnelle ce qu'ils veulent voir
les mines à leur recherche
vous êtes seul dans une ville or on
connaît série à
j'ai eu aussi déléguer mes hommes ils
attendent que votre ex femme pose un
pied à l'extérieur de l'ambassade
1 tu fais de better du daim et alors
elle est à moi
et avec une manière pour moi d'espérer
retrouver
c'est prouvé que j'ai pas commis ce
crime
vous savez ce qui est bien plus
dangereux qu un parfait [ __ ] grisé par
le pouvoir
un homme qui n'a plus rien à perdre